well today was incredibly emotional for
King Charles and queen consult Camilla
in Scotland his sons and their wives
stunned crowds reuniting at Windsor for
the first time in two and a half years
it's been reported that while Harry and
William were both at Balmoral they ate
dinner separately didn't interact and
Harry left for Windsor early the next
morning so what brought them together on
Saturday a text a source tells ET that
the Prince of Wales thought it was an
important show of unity at an incredibly
difficult time for the family as for the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex we're told
they plan to remain in the UK for now
there's no word on whether Archie and
lilybert will attend the Queen's funeral
that's been officially set for next
Monday the 19th we're told that while
Harry is still unable to wear his
military uniform to any event his uncle
prince Andrew is allowed to be in
uniform for the final vigil only and
this was sweet Her Majesty also famously
adored Paddington Bear and his marmalade
sandwiches well it seems so many fans
began leaving these items in tribute
among the flowers that the government
has now actually requested they stopped
the practice quote in the interests of
sustainability
foreign